Speaker 1: Let's move on now to some other right
wing figures who were just gushing or defending
or very impressed with Vladimir Putin's
invasion of Ukraine. And it is absolutely
fascinating to see how the standards that the
right demands be applied to the US-Mexico border.
The very same right ignores in the
context of Putin ignoring the sovereignty
of Ukrainian borders, even though there
are numerous accords that say, actually,
Russia has to respect the Ukrainian borders
and you really have to see this to believe it.
Yesterday, we looked at looked at clips from the
day before in which Tucker Carlson softly defended
Putin's invasion by saying Ukraine is not
even really a democracy and ignoring the fact
that when it came to the US-Mexico border,
Tucker sang a very different tune. Well,
now we have more examples. Candace Owens now
says, Listen, if we just listen to Putin,
we know that this is actually not really Putin's
wrongdoing. Candace Owens tweeting yesterday
quote, I suggest every American who wants to know
what's actually going on in Russia and Ukraine.
Read this transcript of Putin's address, as
I've said for months. Naito, under the direction
from under direction from the United States,
is violating previous agreements and expanding
eastward. We are at fault now. Multiple things
there. OK. First of all, Candace Owens is saying,
just read the transcript. She's basically saying
listen to. But if you don't speak Russian,
you have to read a translated transcript.
Just listen. If you want to know the truth,
listen to what Putin said two nights ago. Anybody
who saw that and had a transcript with them
that they read along, which I did, we should
immediately recognize that it was a confused,
disheveled all over the place, Putin rambling
nonsensically and completely failing to justify
in any legal or moral way his invasion of Ukraine.
But Candace Owens is saying, just listen to what
the authoritarians said and take him at his word
and then you'll understand what's going on. That's
number one. Number two, I've already told you
they are falsely repeating this idea that Naito
is violating agreements by expanding eastward.
I've already talked to you guys about this,
and you can go back and look at my clip from last
week about this. It is not true. It is not true
that Naito had committed to not expand eastward.
There was initially a verbal discussion made
during negotiations decades ago about Naito
not expanding eastward and not ever considering
adding Ukraine. Those were never codified and they
were removed before anything was signed. Now we
can have a reasonable conversation about if you're
Russia, do you consider the eastward expansion
of Naito and the consideration of maybe someday
Ukraine will be part of Naito? If you're Russia,
could you consider that a form of aggression?
Sure, we can. That's absolutely something we
can do. But this idea that Naito is just in the
wrong here, there was an agreement. There was no
such agreement. Next, let's go to Charlie Kirk.
Charlie Kirk sort of also softly runs interference
for Putin by saying, I don't know, guys. I
mean, maybe it's an invasion. Maybe it's not.
But they seem to kind of be welcoming Putin there.
Speaker 3: Why does Putin feel so empowered? The
entire Western world is putting sanctions
right now on Russia, as they call this an
invasion very well. Might. I'm not the I'm
not the person to determine whether that is
an invasion or annexation, it feels as if Putin is
going into places that want him. They have voted
overwhelmingly to be part of it. It's a family
dispute that we shouldn't get in the midst of,
that's for certain. But why does Putin
feel as if now's the perfect time, right?
Well, he definitely waited for the Olympics
to be over for all the cheaters on his team
that weren't even on the Russian Federation
team. It was the Russian Olympic Committee
to be over with. He didn't want the
spectacle in the midst of the Olympics.
He did annex Crimea after the Olympics in
2000, 2006 or 2010. He has a tendency to
do this right after the Olympics or make big
moves. After that, I was talking actually,
Georgia was after the Olympics. We'll get those
dates figured out. But why does Putin feel so?
Let's say compelled at this particular moment
to move, why, why even get close to this?
So in a time when the entire planet is locked down
due to the Chinese coronavirus,
finally the world is reopening.
There's one number in particular that Vladimir
Putin is looking at, that his entire economy is
organized behind and that is the petrodollar.
Speaker 1: OK, so consider that Charlie Kirk
from Turning Point USA has been ranting for years
about Mexico must respect our borders. They are
our borders, they are internationally valid.
They must be respected. But Putin doesn't
have to respect Ukraine's borders, even though
there are actual agreements saying You have to
respect Ukraine's borders. Come on, guys, come
on. And then lastly, here's sort of a bonus.
This is Fox and Friends, Fox and Friends,
actually. They admit Putin is doing a bad boy,
but they say it's Joe Biden's fault.
Speaker 3: Putin is calling those troops
peacekeepers. That's that's the phrase under
the guise of peacekeepers. One man's invader is
another man's peacekeeper. But these two breakaway
regions have been disputed for eight years.
They're not really breakaway. They were taken
along the same time when Crimea was taken
off. And frankly, the reason that it's so
precarious for Ukraine is even Belarus and the
northern part. It's a controlled.
It's controlled by Russia. So an all
look how big that thing is. Yeah, but they don't
cancel Gigantic. It's the second biggest country
in that part of the breadbasket. And those
those Donbas region has huge energy resources,
manufacturing resources. It's been coveted by
Vladimir Putin. And if you listen to what he
said, I mean, the words he used in that
speech were no different than any other
autocrat of the Soviet Union.
Speaker 1: True. I mean, so so far, they're
basically right here. That's what he wants to be.
Speaker 3: He's got one playbook and he first is
going to do it again. The Putin playbook.
He's done this before. When he when he went
in to when everything happened with Georgia
Speaker 4: back, the experts are wondering if
she's going to stop with these regions and they
worry he wants to go farther and farther and then
eventually take over the Black Sea. China and
Taiwan are watching. He knows how Biden handled
Afghanistan. That was a disaster. Last two
embassies, he's lost the Afghanistan embassy,
and now the Ukrainian Embassy has moved
to Poland when he was vice president.
Benghazi happened, and even we know that.
Speaker 1: That's why this is happening, guys.
It's because Benghazi happened when Biden was
VP and Biden left Afghanistan. So now that's why
Putin is doing this. So no matter what, no matter
what, this is either something that's fine or it's
something that's not fine and it's Joe Biden's
fault. That's the analysis from right wing media.
We'll have these clips on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.